m'ont donné je vois il apporte la police
venue en cg pas discréditer ces idées
moi non mais je suis pas en train de
vous juger mais pourquoi vous êtes
devenu policier en 2010 est pas
franchement évident mais d'accord mais
la question là là les policiers ils
s'engagent les policiers ont bien leur
vie ils s'en prennent plein la gueule en
ce moment je n'ai sont réengagés mais le
problème c'est pourquoi vous rendez
compte quand vous ridiculiser la police
à j'ai pu dire qu'est ce que vous
répondez
mais moi je suis choqué meurtri
d'actualiser la police mais pas du tout
quand je fais comme je disais à tout à
l'heure quand je suis comme moi je vois
les messages des gens qui me suivent
mais les gens qui m'apprécient c'est pas
c'est par ici pas de les conduire sur
sam 7 millions d'habitants il n'y a pas
dix mille le mec sur le réseau réseaux
sociaux il faut arrêter d'accord mais
dans les 67 habitat en maniant la
naissance dans les soixante d'années
sincèrement je suis sûr que c'est mitigé
moi de ce que j'ai en retour c'est de
bon c'est pour tourner une image
positive je véhicule de la paix je ris
pas des familles de véhicules
aucun message de haine j'ai même des
collègues policiers qui sont en arrêt
depuis un moment qui m'envoyait on n'en
peut plus ça fait du bien tu donnes du
renouveau j'ai pas mal de messages
positifs je dis pas ça parce que je sais
moi c'est un générique institut depuis
depuis aujourd'hui non mais au bout d'un
moment je crois sur voir les choses
réelles suivre sur sur sur le compteur
qu'est ce que vous avez comme on savait
qu'il y avait vos collègues policiers
qui savez vous alliez voir subir ce soir
et vous en émoi bien que qui fait que
personne n'était d'accord avec lui que
c'était lamentable d'avoir un élément
comme ça dans la police nationale tout
simplement et c'est regrettable encore
une fois parce que ce garçon est issu de
la diversité j'aime bien appuyé sur le
mot parce que c'était pourtant on vient
d'inscrire dans la colonne justement non
mais c'est vachement important que son
comportement la nuit mais de façon
évidente à l'image de la police on en a
pas besoin
quelqu'un l'a fait remarquer tout à
l'heure c'est dommage encore une fois
c'est dommage de faire un plus des clips
puisque les clips où on met des claques
dans la tronche en montant une
interpellation c'est pas ça la police
nationale
s'il ya des mecs qui dérape dans la
police nationale ils sont sanctionnés le
clip on te voit en fait un mec ça veut
dire un contrôle ça fait trente six ans
la méthode je la connais et je la
connais encore du cauchemar si si si si
si une vidéo tantôt claude susi souvenir
il se trouve que c'est dommage je sais
new age ces caricatures et la promotion
bière moi moi le sentiment que j'ai
c'est que vous n'étiez pas heureux dans
la police oui c'est possible c'est que
je ne sais pas ce que vous vouliez faire
en fait j'ai l'impression
vous vous êtes trompé de casting c'est à
dire vous êtes arrivé note rien vous
aviez un truc dans la tête vous attardez
pas prisé des annonces est pas tout à
fait comme ça parce que quand vous
démarrez au début zubi avec vous dise
vous disiez tout à l'heure oui dans la
police il ya déjà des comportements
xénophobes
il ya des comportements qui me plaisent
pas ça vous comprenez bien joue bien ça
peut encore plus gêné que vos vidéos tik
tok que vous disiez ça avance et du 5e
mois pour moi il ya de plus gros
problèmes à traiter
moi quand je suis rentré dans la police
parce que l'intérêt j'avoue il ya pas
mal de commentaires sur les réseaux
ouais ça recrute des cassos la revue à
la baisse juste pour info quand j'ai
passé le concours j'étais dans les
meilleures classes et sur les pratiques
aux techniques sur les épreuves
physiques vous étiez au dr et sur
l'oreille pierre d'être policier oui
j'étais bien j'étais russie le rubin
alors pourquoi ce revirement
parce que de moi même moi je vous parle
pas de la session je vois dans mon
expérience de moi même je me suis heurté
à certains comportements à certaines
mentalités ou au bout d'un moment je me
suis dit mais quand je commence à me
lever le matin j'ai une boule au ventre
chorale pour aller au boulot je me sens
plus à ma place mais il faut partir
on reste pas dans la police et les deux
royaumes savez comment ça marche et
statutaires pour démissionner sans payer
si je pars maintenant je paye 2000 euros
joués et honnête avec vous je roule pas
sur l'or gc ca les 12000 euros